hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dream daddy now we
just got done with the beautiful day
with Craig it went wonderfully we got a
kiss on the head it was awesome while
I'm doing my afternood word jumbles I
hear the mail truck pull through the
cul-de-sac I wonder if we got any
coupons today
nice mail person slides a couple letters
in a large yellow envelope through this
slot takes a couple of tries for them to
get in hey my coupons I take a closer
look at the large yellow envelope I
lightly knock on Amanda's door she
probably has headphones on my Enda she
yells through the door I have something
for you I'm kind of busy right now can
you come back later okay just thought
you'd want this big old envelope we got
from HIA immediately Amanda pushes her
door open
horn Institute for the Arts I mean if
you're busy I can come back father
please I entered the envelope which she
tears open with her teeth it's really
bad for your teeth she doesn't seem to
hear me and spits on the uppies envelope
she pulls a letter and gun folds it and
the suspense is killing me this is her
dream school Amanda's face is unreadable
I can't believe this Oh Amanda tosses
the letter aside and gives me a big hug
Congrats sweetie that's amazing and so
proud of you she pulls away and looks at
the letter again oh my god everything
can't believe it got in well of course
you got it you're great student you need
that interview and your photography is
incredible wait dad I know this one's
really expensive and it's so far away I
think for a moment
HIA was one of the most expensive
schools that Amanda applied to I know
she's had her heart set on it for the
longest time it'll be tough we're gonna
make you work I don't even know if I
have a job or anything but maybe I if I
start working we can do something with
that
really of course man two hugs me again
thanks dad okay sweetie we're
celebrating today dinner your choice
wherever you want Amanda I walk along
the Bayside tearing into our foil wrap
burritos from nearby food truck you
could have chosen anywhere in Maple Bay
cost was not a determining factor please
dad I know you know I'm a simple girl
just give me a reto with a view I can't
say I'm mad man and I sit on a patch of
grass and watch ships sail lazily
through the bed and the dorms bright
near a bunch of cafes and they're all
these little galleries nearby and
there's a discount if you bring your
student ID and a man to slow down you're
gonna choke on your read oh I know I'm
just excited
then I mention to students get their own
studio space once they're seniors we all
get the professional photo editing
software for free it's nice to see a man
is so enthusiastic about HIA but I wish
you wouldn't do it between bites of a
burrito I thought I taught her to chew
with her mouth closed what do we my
roommates are gonna be you take a survey
online and they match you with someone
who's good with a similar major and
interests I think we're gonna be best
friends Greg and I were a good roommate
can be a lifelong friend but don't even
get me started on bad roommates oh no
I'm just kidding
we didn't have a bad roommate our only
other roommate was a puppy that Craig
brought home one night we spent a
semester fabricating a story about our
new foreign exchange student had a
really bad cough that sounded exactly
like a dog's bark our car rolled
oh they let you have animals in the
dorms have you got a note saying you
need one I bet I could forge one I think
I'd get a rabbit or maybe a snake or
maybe both with the snake eat the rabbit
though oh boy I think I'll leave that
all up to you she's so excited not only
disappoint her but I need to be real for
a second so you know I had that talk
with mr. Vega I didn't tell you about
the dumpster fire did he what no I don't
want to put a damper on the good news
but I need you to knock it out of the
park these last few months of school
okay if you really want to go to horns
we need that scholarship money I know
you can do it okay I promise I'll try
harder I Pat her on the back think you
can handle a 14-hour Drive to come home
for the holidays it's gonna be some
treacherous ice roads to cross don't
even get me started on the paranormal
occurrences
well it'll be worth it if I get to see
you my eyes immediately well up with
tears
dad don't cry sorry let's stop you're
gonna be cried too dad I can't get tears
in my burrito my Rito it's gonna make it
taste sad pull the man in for a hug and
kiss around the for love you kiddo
love you too pops Oh Deema plier away oh
I've got dads well I've kind of
committed here the good old Craig but
let's do a sweet save just in case we
want to go somewhere else
hey Craig what's up Craig what's up
Craig I really want to get some good
quality time in with Craig last time we
hung out he was so busy with the kids
and fending off flirty moms and I feel
like we barely talked did get a sweet
kiss on the forehead though ever since
the first time we hung out I've been
trying to get up a little early for runs
I don't think I'm gonna be embarrassed
as last time maybe I'll even be able to
catch up with him now tap out a message
I'm on dad books yo what up Craig been
training on the run game ready for round
2 oddly enough I have also been training
on my run game I'm up to four miles yeah
dude of course emojis I don't know I
didn't just send an emoji rather than
another message better than a bunch of
eggplants in my inbox another message
pops into my inbox let's meet up early
tomorrow for my favorite morning
activity brunch brunch I get back brunch
what's that oh you run and then you get
brunch
oh right Greg and I agree to meet at a
time in the morning and I have a chance
to spend the evening hanging out with
Amanda so we doing pizza tonight again
can we do like a salad are you and a
health kick not yet I can form the
committee to examine the possibility of
being on a health kick they haven't
returned with their findings dad if you
go on a health kick then I have to go in
a health kick by virtue of being under
the same roof as you I don't know if I
have the Constitution for it
sorry about it it's time Kraig needs big
crack dudes be alright fine don't worry
about it kragle forgive me maybe yeah
Craig we'll forgive me committee's still
out the committee isn't back with us
fine again this is a multi-year
assessment on several pure Craddock
levels well Amanda picks up the phone
and stares at me unblinking as she dials
hi yes can I get an extra large pizza
with chicken bacon extra cheese and
tomatoes and a couple of the garlic
sauce cups Amanda going a little north
here all right can you maybe throw on
some leaves on there or something yeah
he's going on a health kick yeah Rico I
know it's tragic for a second I'll ask
dad is oregano a salad yeah Rico yep
cashew finds he out of the wife and kids
for me thanks Rico says hey food gets
delivered and we plop down on the couch
and eat some za good day of Rito's and
za
just be careful running his gateway drug
it's a slippery slope at first you go on
a couple of light jobs and before you
know you're converting the garage into a
home gym and renewing your subscription
to some sort of weekly kombucha delivery
service question shoot what's kombucha
so you are too far gone yet
I'm just giving you a hard time pops
really happy you're running more and
caring about your health I want to keep
you around for as long as possible
thanks kiddo speaking of which I'm
running with Craig tomorrow you gonna be
able to keep up with him hey no probably
not
we laugh anymore za ah that is probably
healthy in the name of carbo-loading
I call him night early so that I'm ready
for tomorrow when I first started
running in the mornings it was pretty
hellish now that I'm a few sessions in
and mitad Lee has become a little bit
easier despite it always ending in me
dry heaving over a trash can is that
what the runner's high is just dry
heaving I lace up my tennis shoes throw
on a t-shirt from the writers summon I
went to 20 years ago and had out the
door at a moderate jog Craig is already
outside with the river strapped to his
chest and the baby's gonna get sick he's
dressed head-to-toe in color coordinated
running gear Wow I look like a total
slob next to this guy I think anyone
would look like a total schlub next to
that guy hey bro morning Craig rivers
gonna
running with us mrs. she can we're
taking it to the limit aren't we kiddo
oh I know what she that means Greg hands
are a stuffed toy which makes me smile
ear to ear
that's Arnold the capybara sometimes is
the only thing that'll get her to stop
crying oh I've been there man a stuffed
panda that she cared around everywhere
she would have a tantrum if we even
tried to wash it it's gross
she even running lately every morning
for 30 minutes I'm basically an elite
athlete at this point well I'll try to
keep up so where we added that we can do
a couple laps around the park okay that
sounds reasonable then we'll do some
hill climbs up a slope okay I can
probably handle that close it off by
doing some wilderness survival hike
running to increase our agility no we'll
jump off into the ocean to swim with the
sharks punch whew dick it'll be all
right cool boy go through the Sahara
Desert for about 13 fortnight's yeah
we'll have a good time over there
traversing over the Himalayan mountains
I'm suddenly struck with the
overwhelming need to crawl back into bed
that sounds okay to you right I usually
like to throw some time murder sprints
in there but I'll go easy on you since
you're a beginner Oh murder sprints you
say I know what that is and how nice
that sounds that that sounds like
something I'm able to physically do
great let's get started okay cool
Greg and I finally arrived at the park a
few other lone joggers make their way
around the perimeter and river waves
enthusiastically of everyone we pass
it's a lot more peaceful in the
morning's aside from bird chirping and
river gurgling away in the stroller it's
pretty quiet stroller stroller stroller
where's said stroller
all right good warm-up let's start the
show
wait Greg reaches into his bag and cost
me a water bottle i fumble it but
thankfully don't drop it
you got a hydrate bro take a long drink
from the water bottle in the field
reinvigorated man I don't drink enough
water hey I look down and pick up Arnold
rivers toy and hand it back to her wants
to drop this thanks for looking out bro
you ready bro is collapsing in on itself
we finally finished our however many
teen lap around the park I'm breathing
heavily I can't believe actually didn't
lose Greg he's even breathing heavily -
which makes me feel a little better look
down my shirt and notice I'm drenched in
sweat huh almost looks like a frowny
face
that's one what I'm just kidding good
hustle out there I'm really impressed
you're way better than last time I
launched you off a treadmill yeah man
you really pushed me to my limit just
now can't believe I held on so I'm gonna
be there to push you to do your absolute
best I'm glad I could be that guy bro
we're close BLAP here's my little
cheerleader mark you ready I'm just
gonna give a moderate I don't need to
pull out all here oh there we go you bet
Greg takes me to a separate portion of
the park here where there's a still
steep climb that seems to go up forever
I strained my eyes to see some other
joggers at the top so what do we do now
we run up the thing that there's two
things you need to know about this hill
one don't stop running till you get to
the top and two points at the top of the
hill that's not the top okay now it's
good time for the aw I finally reached
the top of a laughter making my way past
what I originally thought was the top of
the hill once there I hunched over to my
knees and gasp for errors my lungs are
like daggers poking my ribs I can feel
my heart in my ears River I'm having a
moment police oh boy
Greg looks like he's taking a beating as
well so he is human put your arms on
your head and stretch out your elbows
it'll help you breathe better I do as
Craig says it feels a little better but
I'm still in agony and here Greg tossing
me the water bottle again I hydrated
like my life depends on it thanks dude
but now I'm gonna work you keep feel
that lightness in your head that's the
runner's high
oh that's it I thought I was I thought I
was dying
want to take it slow for a bit I would
like
please yes please as we're catching our
breath River starts crying what's wrong
sweet pea do you want to play with
Arnold Greg looks around us oh boy man
down I think we lost Arnold river keeps
whaling I've abandoned my child's kind
of fine dude should be simple right we
just got to retrace our steps
remember river house having it at the
bottom of the hill great and I jogged
down the path a searching high and low
for the stuff capybara which Craig takes
the time to explain to me is a large
rodent native to South America we get to
the place where River might have dropped
it but it's still nowhere to be looks
like we've got a mystery on our hands we
have to get to the bottom of this I
suspect foul play looks like this is a
prime case for world renowned detective
EEP Lee air the newest Blair dude it's
time for a bro venture bro venture we
high-five and decide to jog back to the
park to see if we can find any leads so
it looks like there's a couple more
places you're checking some bros around
here they'll get interrogated sounds
good wait who's good cop who's bad cop I
think that with your stature and overall
resilience you would make an
intimidating bad cop but on the other
hand you do have an adorable baby
strapped to your chest so that softens
the edges abandon all valid points I
think you'd make a great good cop
because you're congenial attitude and
willingness to try new things but then
again see now you get when there are too
many commercial breaks are in the show
so you have the potential to be a scary
bad cop I don't have to watch meat hell
in three minute segments of five minute
commercials in between loud too loud
Jason boy let's play moment by moment
I'll be bad cop
so we're too protective oh go to the
woods let's go to the woods make our way
to the Oscars of the park there are a
couple of benches by the dense tree line
looks like Roberts been here all by
himself
this also seems like the perfect place
to look for clues interrogate Robert
Robert excuse you oh here oh hi you're
Robert hey don't call me that
okay hi Robert don't call me that either
okay hey what are you up to you digging
is my thinking bench I have to get a
solid two to three hours brooding per
day filling quotas if you by chance seen
a small tough capybara around a capybara
is it's a large rodent native to South
America I know so you seen one stuff one
not a real one they'll be weird I'm
gonna be back all right Robert
we've been nice elbows out I'm gonna go
off learn how to fight they'll come back
here to kick your ass you learned how to
fight these fine you don't tell us what
we want to hear boil the season finale
of long haul paranormal I shrugged ghost
rockers my buddy Hugh doesn't play by
the rules
Markel do it Callum infringe op you must
you Robert sighs I haven't seen any
goddamn cat the beer okay
damn all that bad copper nothing we're
gonna search through the outskirts of
the woods hoping to find anything that
might lead a startle there are a couple
of cigarettes and empty beer cans
scattered around this probably is the
hotspot for edgy teen staying out at
night I'd say swears and stuff but it
doesn't look like there were any recent
activity that might be capybara related
it might be a dead-end partner bro we
return to the woods
well we already interrogated Robert what
would be the point of doing time to
grill him again
all right okay yeah I'm gonna keep being
vaguely threatening kill you jelly time
than usual told you haven't seen the
capybara damage damn again we're an abra
we make our way over to the small
playground the edge of the park a couple
of kids play on the jungle gym my
parents watch on nearby bench we're on
one of the benches I spot a familiar
face
let's see what Joseph subdued be
engrossed in a book there Jonesy does it
nearly drops his book I didn't think I'd
see you guys out here mark are you
exercising sure am you know me I just
love to run and health that's my kind of
whole thing what are you oh just a book
on knots and rope tying last weird but
okay for boats boat rope right hey you
didn't happen to see a stiff capybara
around here
what's a capybara it's a large rodent
it's native to South America
Joseph thanks for a second hmm I haven't
seen one around I'll tell the kids to
keep an eye out your kids are here just
look around they were here a second ago
must have gone exploring around the park
you know kids are you know where they
could have run off to their game
mischief sometimes but they always come
back
sounds a little suspect Joseph mischief
you say hi oh wait am I being
interrogated right now I see no just
doing our due diligence Joseph Arnold
means a lot to River here I mean if
you're more than welcome to ask
Christian and Christie I imagine they'd
been ears to the ground on all the
latest parade around drama they might be
somewhere around the woods thanks Joseph
we'll get back to you lady give it a row
book ropes we got back to the playground
look for clues Craig and I two grown
adults walk onto the playground and
begin examining the meticulously curve
for clues no forensic evidence no stray
capybara after citric food illusion for
time to look up all the parents are
staring at us it's my own wave as we
awkwardly slink away we've got a baby
screaming that doesn't help our
situation here Oh buddy got a rain check
on brunch I need to get river home and
calm her down
all right good luck bro thanks bro did
go badly
[ __ ] hang on wait no no I'm not
gonna do that no no no no
nah no way no way no how no way hang on
here Oh
we bought time with the playground for
River I forgot to read that's okay she's
about to go nuclear this might prepare
for the possibility of us not being able
to find Arnold life is cruel and tough
but at least we need a always have
swings great straps River into the baby
swing gives her a gentle push she
giggles take a seat on the swing next to
her and immediately realism stuck River
seems to love that Craig eventually
helps me out of the swing and we decide
to go back to the investigation all
right we're back on the case alright
let's move on to another part of the
park
there's nothing here anyway I've deduced
where we should go next gotta go to the
fields we wander out of the grass field
the center of the park there isn't a
whole lot to see but there a few figures
camped out on a blanket and the grass
could hold any number of secrets Madden
Carmencita talked to Matt and his
daughter Carmen see the spot size from
across the way she's sitting down with
her dad on Sun a green patch grass we
jogged over hey bro we just sat down for
a picnic want some snacks and I think to
increase my glycogen reserves thank you
very much
tiny bro but I should be fine guys we're
good yep I'm the picture of health and
athleticism good resume mark say have
you seen a stuffed capybara around here
anywhere or have you hmm
what's a capybara large wrote his name
in South America
wait a second how do you know what a
capybara is you wouldn't think more
suspicious that you know what a
caperberry is hey God took Arnold what
if I'm the culprit really check my body
for a Polaroids I may have kept on my
person to remind me oh I know not to try
I saw my mentor once that I'm pretty
sure that's how it works anyway nothing
well what if that's what I want my self
no mark don't let them win shake off the
thought I saw a couple of squirrels over
by that tree I don't know if the helps
but if you want to see some cute
squirrels you should definitely check it
out thanks for the hot squirrels kid tip
tip Carmencita nice well we better get
moving
gotta find that capybara before the
river as a breakdown good luck
Carmencita hooks me up with some road
slices we're on our way see ya back to
the field interrogate riff yeah wait let
me try this it's always the culprit you
least expect
I get eye to eye with River who still
looks on the [ __ ] like she's on the
verge of tears nice yeah nice
interrogate my baby imma be bad cop
where's Arnold River starts crying
uncontrollably whoops oh oh oh
oh no no nope nope that didn't happen
that wasn't the way that works that
didn't happen I yelled that up baby hey
sweetie believe me nobody wants to find
a capybara more than me we need Clues I
think somewhere in that baby brain of
yours you might have something that
leads us to the perp I turn to Craig
we're getting nowhere with the witness
oh all right fine then check out the
squirrels
hey cool squirrels the suspects say the
squirrels would be tree uh-huh there
they are
yeah come and see that was telling the
truth these are some rats squirrels
River seems happy this may have bought
us some extra time all right any clues
see can't seem to find them well I'm
looking
Craig calls me out from across the field
mark hi I jog over Craig is kneeling in
the grass inspecting something I
approached my heart my throat as they
leaned over Craig I see it this is I put
my hand over rivers eyes no one should
have to be subjected to this senseless
violence oh my god what do this I don't
know I think we might be dealing with
something beyond our grasp I can't look
at this anymore
I turn around trying to wipe the image
of stuffing strewn across the ground
from my mind we're running out of time
we may already be too late
back in tagging let's keep moving move
her back to the field clock's ticking
dude we're going next this is the big
kahuna ain't it I think we got to go
back to the woods something bout Robert
don't rub me right
last night but that's not the point
Joseph's twins must be around here
somewhere
Robert hey okay not again Robert crap
now what bro Joseph steady Twitter
around here somewhere but I have no idea
what to find them we there's TP kids you
didn't tell me they had something to do
with this huh maybe I should have left
the good cop bad cop routine to the pros
on the TV yeah Robert bro do you know
where they are I do a lot of people
underestimate the sense of a man who
brutes I said I'm learning where they go
ran into the woods I'd be careful though
not a trust you man but then again I
don't trust anyone not even you guys not
even that baby to get back you know silk
you know thanks for your help Robert go
deeper into the woods visit this is the
one
let me save just in case of [ __ ] it up
again stare into the depths of the
forest who knows what could be in there
are you prepared for what we might face
in there no on second thought I think
they might be able to smell the fear on
me maybe we should give that in a minute
to dissipate seconded the woods
oh wait no hang on no that's not what I
wanted yeah I'm ready I'm ready partner
bro you know but if you give rivers to
stop crying I don't care let's do this
we start down the path into the woods
keeping their eyes and ears peeled for
any sign of Arnold words anywhere the
silence is unsettling the Sun can barely
peek through the canopy it's colder here
suddenly we hear voices I want to do it
you gonna do it last time clearing we're
fine Christian Christina kneeling over
something right there criminal scum put
your tiny hands where we can see them
Christian and Christie just stare at us
you're the guy put your hands up okay in
the middle of something here yeah can
you come back later you kids doing
cutting stuff up or just pounding is
this just the end of the line I step
closer I can't believe what I'm seeing
pair of safety scissors lie in the dirt
it's Arnold was redundant really Arnold
gube you're the baby hand over the
capybara no fair Finders Keepers
no not finders keepers that's our
poverty and you desecrated it how can
you prove it's yours
Craig holds up Arnold severed leg they
have to look away you got sloppy you
left evidence behind but I think you'll
find that this leg fits perfectly on his
body
Christian Christie look at each other
they don't know what to do how about a
deal
capybara and we won't tell your dad
about this fine Yan's over the stuffed
animal give us no safety scissors
clearly not only longer safe in your
hands she hands him over glad we can
figure this out come on partner Craig
and I start making our way out of the
woods he turns around and calls back to
the twins tell your dad to stop letting
you watch true crime shows with the
capybara backed with its rightful owner
Craig and I shamble into a nearby diner
exhausted from our adventure we find
ourselves a corner booth and settle in
that was a tough case but we cracked it
bro we're different now changed if we
get in too deep nice it's nothing a
hardy bronze can fix my stomach grumbles
I suddenly realize how big of an
appetite I worked up brunch
give me brunch I have a strong
philosophies on brunch you see the first
thing you do is divide your brunch is
between boobie Brunton upper-class
mimosas Eggs Benedict brunch and grimy
brunch then give me a coffee and bacon
and cheesy hash browns brunch there's
time in a place where both and I think
most of life is figuring out which one
you need me so what kind of brunch dad
are you mark God give me a grimy brunch
every any day I don't need a boozy
brunch get me grimy a fine choice
between going on a health kick got a got
a carbo load get a carbo load I'm
carbo-loading carbo no flank amount of
cheesy potatoes O'Brien to refuel after
run rye bread it's not even remotely out
carbo loading works this is your kid you
betcha she's so cute how you hey kid
middle school is gonna be real tough but
if you make it through then you can make
it through anything
the waitress walks away after winking at
Craig seems like you're the most
eligible dad and bachelor town guess so
hey where here's the thing about brunch
you don't do business during brunch
brunch is a time for rest relax
in restoration with those that you love
while we're having brunch at a
traditionally brunch time the most
important thing to remember is that
brunch isn't if I can't have brunch on
your plate you can always have brunch in
your heart I disagree with you I just
don't know if I could match her
intensity I'll open your eyes bro
just wait you order our food in the
waitress after very blatantly hitting on
Craig multiple times he eventually
brings our brunch of East River munches
on cereal right next to us more or less
managing to get it into her mouth I
gotta say man she's a great having you
back around to hang out with I think
you've been so busy with work and
fitness and kids just haven't had time
to really go out and get to know people
with you here it's like man if a new new
place could have been really rough for
me especially with the man of going off
to college soon making this a lot easier
Craig smiles at me feels really good to
go another bro venture with you dude
just like old times for a while I forget
about it anything that was bothering me
in my life and it was just you man well
copy oh so do you like work out yeah
mostly calisthenics by I try to lift as
part of the regimen ah I wish I could
help you out but I'm enjoying brunch
when I work out bro right now hello I'm
here my name is markiplier well if you
change your mind
the waitress slides a folded note to
Craig and walks away Craig makes a face
and reluctantly puts it in his pocket we
can't take you anywhere can we it's a
blessing and a curse isn't it
next time we hang out should be in the
middle of the woods where people can't
interrupt us and also maybe in some
different woods than the ones we are
where little kids like to vivisect
things Greg laughs man remember all our
camping road trips back in the day
Joshua Tree hell yeah Yellowstone now is
the best give anything to do it all over
again
dude we should go on a camping weekend
oh I don't know bro I don't know have
all these don't responsibilities I don't
think I could just drop everything to
hang out in the woods for a few days you
know come on dude if we plan things
right we can do this Greg don't you ever
do anything for yourself
Creek stairs and whose gun
of course I do yeah like what sometimes
I let my health self a wooden scoop of
vanilla ice cream before bed but only if
I didn't mean my caloric intake for the
day sometimes I let myself hit the
snooze alarm but only once
dude you gotta relax sometimes or it's
gonna kill you please come camping with
me it'd be so fun bro because I could
get smashley to take the kids for the
weekend I'll think about it we finish
our brunches have head back to the
cul-de-sac by the way great job keeping
up today seems like you're already
making a lot of progress I'm probably
gonna need a little bit of recovery
after this tell the girls I said hello I
will see you protective I say goodbye to
Craig we step inside gotta Mary for a
shower gallon water in it nap crack open
her door to find her still in bed
sleepily scrolling through her phone
morn and afternoon actually
right how was brunch good side tracked
before because we had to travel into the
depths of maple plays dark underbelly to
find a toy river drop but you know I
actually feel pretty I miss all on the
floor of the hallway take your time
didn't up see you around the bend
Oh
I got points I don't know you're sure
amazing college I've missed you dude oh
that's so nice
Oh anyway so that is the end of this
episode god I love this game it's so fun
it's so fun anyway so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm gonna
keep going on with this I don't know how
long there's a lot of daddies to date
out there so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]